as a chef i know it's not what you spend
on ingredients but results on the plate
that count
using cheap cuts and leftovers and
working them hard in the kitchen gives
you food in a budget that tastes a
million bucks
and i'm going to show you how
first up my flavor packed lamb with
fried bread
whether i'm cooking high-end dishes or
rustic dishes trust me it all has to be
impressive so this lamb dish proves that
you don't have to spend a fortune to
create delicious food
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just here because you can
see that delicious bone running through
the center and that's full of marrow so
that just gives the lamb a nice added
sweet flavor
just take your knife cut through each
end this stops the
lamb steak from buckling so therefore it
cooks
evenly and colors beautifully so and
pepper
lamb needs quite a lot of help with the
pepper so
be quite generous with the pepper
and just pat that down
the pan is just under smoke on the
outside now put the oil in get that pan
really nice and hot because this is a
cheap cut so
i'm depending on the color of the lamb
steak to really sort of impart a lot of
flavor
that's the noise you want to hear you
can't hear that noise don't drop the
steak in
put a little bit of garlic in there not
chopped garlic just whole cloves the
garlic lightly crushed
don't even waste time peeling them in
tongs lift up
that bit of fat around the back
that's the top of the leg
tilt the pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat it works brilliantly
when you're cooking a rib eye as well
cut it over
that color beautiful
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we've got that nice even sear
all over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan
and vase
and basting the lamb steak
just means you're sort of adding all
that nice scented
garlic olive oil back into the lamb
useful
now take the lamb out let the lamb rest
[Music]
neutral
[Music]
now
for the perfect rustic crouton so this
bread's quite firm a couple of days old
just slice it straight down the center
dice it up
put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
[Music]
from there i'm gonna add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture
and just let that milk sort of absorb
into the bread while that's soaking i'm
gonna make the dressing go back to that
initial garlic that was in the pan
look at that beautiful into the pest and
water anchovies
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
i want that nice salty vinegary flavor
and a bit of kick some capers
the little baby cats very sweet
now just pound that to a nice paste
that smells incredible
next some dijon mustard
a nice teaspoon and a half in a little
bit of red wine vinegar two tablespoons
and then our extra virgin olive oil
now
it's got that heat in there i've got a
nice roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinaigrette that sort of seeps into that
lamb
some fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley
delicious flavour parsley in
nice
now get your pan hot for the croutons
olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all the
excess milk out not too hard i don't
want them dry
and in
and then just fry them
and the milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor
that's the color i want
nice
now take them out and lightly drain them
a little bit kitchen roll onto the board
out
[Music]
it's a plateman just take this amazing
vinaigrette
and spread it
get those croutons
listen to them
like little boulders hitting the play
the lamb
sit that on
next one
on
the rest of the croutons
on
now use all those little bits
and my chef in paris would kill me right
now if you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits
croutons on
and then just
drop that sauce on all those little
bits of the lamb
and there that is a perfect way
of taking a cheap cut
into the premier league of dishes
vegetables are such an asset in the
kitchen healthy fantastically fresh and
incredibly versatile and pound for pound
they're so much cheaper than fish or
meat just make sure you give them plenty
of attitude
my homemade gnocchi
making your enoki is so simple to do yet
the results are absolutely stunning and
it's a great way of using up leftover
baked potatoes
you can make gnocchi just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it a nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture cut
them in half take your spoon
and scoop the inside of those potatoes
i'm using leftover baked potatoes but
this really works as well with leftover
ball potatoes two choices you can get a
fork and sort of mash the potato and get
it nice and light and fluffy or
this little gadget it's called a ricer i
suppose it's a posh word
for a potato masher just squeeze gently
you can see how nice and light it is
almost like fluffy little strands of
potato
you can do this when the potatoes are
hot it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now
a nice spoon of okata ring a little
touch of salt and pepper it's really
important to season the mixture as we go
along otherwise the nokia becomes really
bland
flour over the ricotta sieved so there's
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now
make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft
pliable ball of dough
give that a really good mix
get some thyme flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant and it's
just a really nice herb and with the
ricotta
it tastes brilliant just pick the little
tips the time flowers
next flour your hands generously and
knead the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth as it
starts to get a little bit wet
and just add a little touch of flour we
want something really nice and soft now
don't overwork it
it stops the nokia from expanding when
it hits the pan
that's exactly what i want a nice sort
of soft
fragrant ball cut the ball in half
lightly flour
the hands and just roll it
gently
just think of a a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now
lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi it doesn't stick
cut the dough into bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down
why i want my knocking to look like a
pillow
and for me the most important part there
is that not one of them are identically
the same shape
water on
bring it up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there
lightly flour your hand
lift up the gnocchi
in to the rolling boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom and let them simmer and
they start to sort of tell you they're
cooked when they start floating get a
pan on
get that nice and hot now they're just
starting to come up to the top and you
can continue cooking them like that i
like blanching them in the water take
them out and then frying them to study
the gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying
pan
gently lift up and look
they've doubled in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside
nokia loves fresh pepper
so
pepper in
you can see as i start turning them got
this really nice little sort of
brown
color
and they almost popping up now like
little parcels so i want them nice and
sauteed both sides but light
and creamy
in the center
fresh garden peas
in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of
bernoulli flavor on the end
beautiful
put a little bit of fresh thyme over the
peas and then finally i want to lift it
up fresh lemon
zest the lemon over
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated parmesan cheese give
your vegetable attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook and
absolutely stunning my next recipe is a
proper british classic that's super
simple to cook and cost next to nothing
a delicious apple crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruit's at its absolute
best
[Music]
first off i'm gonna make a really nice
light caramel pan on nice and low great
to apples
[Music]
this helps to almost sort of pure the
apples so much quicker
there's a lot of flavor in the skin so
don't worry about peeling the fruit
whether it's pears plums peaches
flavors in the skin
nice
to start the caramel a couple of
tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps to
get rid of the tartness in the apple
a touch of cinnamon that starts to make
it a little spicy open up your vanilla
just scrape out all those seeds
now this just makes it light and
fragrant all those seeds
in
to the sugar when making caramel be
patient and always swirl the dish
instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes brown add the apple
that starts to sort of cool down the
caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelised puree
apple's almost disintegrating
smells incredible
turn the gas down
slice up two apples
it's a crumble that's got no frills
straight forward no faffing around no
peeling of the skin
i want them to sort of stand out from
the caramel
apples in
now those nice thick chunks of apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
and chewy
i want it to sort of taste zesty spicy
so
sip the lemon zest on top of your apples
and cranberry
fresh lemon juice over and that just
gives that extra acidic kick takes the
cranberries the apples the caramel and
the cinnamon to another level turn the
gas off
so that that sits
and let's concentrate on the crumble
flour in
a couple of tablespoons of demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy
butter in
[Music]
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
a bread crumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the demerara sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting
in that flour
so that's the basic crumble mix
but i'm not finished yet
muesli
two-thirds crumble
one-third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
i want the crispiness on the top
the puree on the bottom of the caramel
and then the texture
in the center a good tip
turn the gas back on i want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so as soon
as you see
that caramel start to bubble down the
side in she goes
let's go
bake at 200 degrees celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
[Music]
beautiful
it's still bubbling
[Music]
and look at it
a delicious but very simple crumble with
apples at the absolute best
beautiful
[Music]
you